you came to the press screening last
night to introduce the movie yes and you
said I'm hard to work out the suicides
go out and kind of in Suicide Squad
brain is it a reboot what's happening
can you tell me you know these terms are
also narrow there's so many terms yeah
it is what it is understand I love this
guy
Elizabeth Charlie's Angels very excited
about that question
the last franchise we got Destiny's
Child we got a bob we got independent
women could we get another original song
coming oh I got some stuff up my sleeve
okay maybe there is tomomi Brandon
James you're no stranger to hard you're
no stranger to the superhero genre what
was it for you about blending let's talk
about blending genres here because this
was such a cool unique concept yeah I
just think of it as a mashup I think of
it as taking all the things I love about
superhero movies and all the things I
love about horror movies and putting it
together and one thing I think at its
heart though it is however horrible
really you know I mean it's got the face
of a superhero movie but underneath it
what you really have is a horror film
that O's is much too supernatural horror
you know and maybe even more so than it
does to any Supergirl film first of all
I love the mashup idea I mean it was
very visual from the script even and the
idea of the iconography with iconography
of superheroes but mostly I felt like it
was a movie for me as Tory about
parenting how do parents a kid that's
different you know and I'm a mom I have
two little boys and you're constantly
you know wondering like what are they
gonna be like when they're big answered
pretty quickly I love horror and I
thought that this was a real opportunity
to play with tropes and a really
interesting and fun way and like
surprise the audience the whole time but
also make like a really nice family
story at the heart of it yeah it is
interesting that cuz like when you think
about Superman you're like why the hell
would they take this alien child it ya
[ __ ] here's a thing in a spaceship love
you raise it as my own and home and ends
up okay he's gonna be let's make them
good what but also like miss making
right like we all have mythology around
like our childhoods to like you know
like I'm there's a whole story about
when I was born and I had pneumonia and
I was you know baptized five times and I
made it there but it's like part of my
mythology like being baptized kept
thinking I was gonna die and they want
to make sure I went to heaven we can
talk about that but mythology in your
right like we all have those like
moments like you know you see great
singers there's always like the video
like though they play the piano and
there were three right you know it's
like in bright burn its well I mean you
know he crushed us he was seven I guess
we should have seen it coming when he
like rose to greatness
[Music]